an alternative rock band hinder is
headed to las vegas tomorrow at virgin
hotels and we have one of the band
members joining us live right now so
we're going to check in with them
hopefully you can hear us hello how are
you
i'm great how are you good we're so
excited to have you out here in las
vegas tell us a little bit about the
tour and what people can expect at the
show
uh yeah we're just uh starting our
second leg today so we're traveling from
our hometown of oklahoma city uh out
there today so we're we're in the bus
right now on our on our way there but uh
you know it's just it's gonna be a good
time you know we're always looking for
uh to just throw a big party and make it
a good time for everyone
i'm just gonna ask you are you in your
tour bus right now so cool that we're
gonna get in that behind-the-scenes look
with you and how great is it to be back
on tour after you know everything kind
of abruptly stopped back in 2020
oh it's it's it's so exciting you know
uh
during those times it was you know
uncertain for everyone and
so for us to be able to get back out and
do what we love and meet all the people
it's uh i don't know it's great it's
very exciting time and you guys have so
many great hits and such great music but
i know everyone always waits to hear
lips of an angel i'm sure you guys kind
of play it at the end make everyone wait
around to hear their favorite song but
we gotta talk about it that video has
over 260 million views on youtube it's
so crazy did you guys think that song
would be as big of a hit as it is and
still is today
uh you know you always hope and dream
but uh no i i never could have imagined
that that that song would take on you
know the life that it did so uh yeah
it's free it's pretty cool pretty
surreal yeah always a favorite and have
you guys performed out here in las vegas
before
we have yeah several times that's one of
our one of our favorite spots
yeah i was going to ask you you know we
love when people come to visit our city
do you have something you love the most
about las vegas i'm sure the crowd and
the energy too is like unlike anywhere
else
obviously uh yeah i mean the people are
great uh you know just just the overall
energy like you said and you know the
scenery the lights um you know and we
have we have a lot of really good
friends out there one of our one of our
past producers who lives out there has a
great studio there so it's always great
to catch up with friends
awesome well we can't wait to have you
guys all out here safe travels on your
tour bus and we'll see you out here
tomorrow night thanks for joining us
thank you so much i appreciate it and
you can check hinder out tomorrow night
at 24 oxford at virgin hotels uh doors
open at 8 pm and tickets start at just
28 rocky over to you what is this